SUBPOENA FOR THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
STEALING GREAT REPORTING AND
WATCHING IT TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US NOW
THROUGH ACTION, AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK, THE SEQUEL, THE
SECOND IN THE SERIES.
WITCH HUNT.
ON THE HEELS OF HIS NUMBER ONE
BEST SELLER, THE STORY OF THE
GREATEST MASS DELUSION AND GET
AMERICA HISTORY BEER THAT IT IS,
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT AND TOM FITTON.
WE'LL START WITH GREG.
YOU HAD A GREAT COLUMN ABOUT
ANNIE McCABE AND HIS RISE TO
POWER TODAY.
WE ARE STILL AWAITING WHETHER OR
NOT HE IS GOING TO BE INDICTED
FOR LYING AND LEAKING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
BUT ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
LIED AND LEADS, THEY ENDED UP,
LET'S GO TO THE LIST,
GENERAL FLYNN, SET UP BY THE WAY
THAT I McCABE AND KONY IN A
WAY THAT DENIED HIM I BELIEVE
HIS MIRANDA RIGHTS.
AND WE'VE GOT MEN A FORT AND
COHEN AND COHEN AND PAPADOPOULOS
BUT WHY WOULD NOT APPLY TO
McCABE AND CALL ME?
>> ALL, YOU ARE RIGHT.
LOOK, ANDREW MCCABE IS A GUY WHO
IS HELPED PUT PEOPLE BEHIND BARS
FOR LYING.
THE SAME LEGAL STANDARD OUGHT TO
APPLY TO HIM IF THERE IS ANY
JUSTICE IN OUR SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE.
THIS WAS A CRIMINAL REFERRAL BY
A NEUTRAL PARTY AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
THEY SAID HE LED NOT ONLY ONCE
BUT FOUR TIMES.
HE SAID HE NEVER LEAKED
INFORMATION TO THE MEDIA,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
IN FACT, HE DID.
HE SAID HE HAD NO IDEA WHO
AUTHORIZE THAT LEAK WHEN IN
FACT, HE'S THE ONE WHO
AUTHORIZED IT AND THEN, HE WAS
ALLOWED TO CORRECT THE RECORD
AND IN A TAPE-RECORDED INTERVIEW
CONTINUE TO SPEW HIS FOLK'S
DENIALS.
SO AGAIN, IF WE ARE GOING TO
APPLY AN EQUAL STANDARD OF
JUSTICE AND NOT SELECTIVE
PROSECUTION BASED ON POLITICS,
ANDREW MCCABE ON TO BE
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
TOLD ME EARLIER TODAY THAT IS
VERY CLOSE TO ALL OF THIS IS
THAT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS YOU
HAVE IF A DEMOCRAT IS INDICTED
AND THE TRIAL TAKES PLACE IN
D.C., ODDS ARE A THOUSAND TIMES
BETTER THAT THE DEMOCRATS GET
BETTER TREATMENT THAN A
REPUBLICAN.
IT AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
KEEP HEARING IS THAT THEY ARE
WAITING FOR THE FULL STORY
BEFORE THEY MOVE FORWARD.
THERE ARE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
WITH ANY
LEGAL ACTION AN INDICTMENT AND
THE GRAND JURY.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> WILL, THE IDEA THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE A DEMOCRATIC JURY I THINK
IS JUST EXCUSE MAKING IF
THAT IS THE STANDARD, NO
DEMOCRAT WILL EVER BE INDICTED
FOR CORRUPTION HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT CAN'T BE THE EXCUSE AGAIN
BECAUSE THAT'S A GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE CARD FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
LIBERALS DATA DIMINISHMENT
RUNNING THIS TOWN EVEN THOUGH
TRUMP IS PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
IDEA THAT YOU WOULD WAIT FOR THE
BIG STUFF WHILE EXONERATING THEM
AND REFUSING TO PROSECUTE THEM
FOR THE LITTLE STUFF FOR THE
RESPONSE OUGHT TO BE THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING THIS PART OF A
BROADER INVESTIGATION AND WE ARE
GOING TO DEFER OUR PROSECUTION
DECISION UNTIL WE HAVE ALL THE
FLIES OF MATERIAL AND IF INDEED
THAT IS THE REAL REASONING HERE
BUT YOU KNOW, MR. McCABE, YOU
KNOW, WE JUST HAD DOCUMENTS COME
OUT A WEEK OR SO AGO.
I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT IT HERE.
14 LEAKS EXPOSED AT THE SENIOR
LEVELS OF THE FBI.
FBI SPECIAL AGENTS.
NOW ONE PROSECUTION AND ONE OF
THOSE LEAKS HIGHLIGHTED THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT WE RECEIVED AND
TO THE AND THE DETAIL IS, CANCEL
LACK OF CANDOR UNDER OATH AND
LACK OF CANDOR IT NOT UNDER
OATH.
BOTH OF WHICH COULD BE CRIMES IF
ANY OTHER AMERICAN COMMITTED IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
McCABE'S DESIRE TO GO AFTER
FLYNN AND AMBUSHED FLYNN WITH
THOSE FBI AGENTS SENT OVER WITH
STROKE.
THE IDEA THAT FLYNN WHO DID NOT
LIE TO THE FBI THEN ACCORDING TO
THE EVIDENCE THAT THIS MAN WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO GET AWAY WITH
LYING TO INVESTIGATORS BOTH
UNDER OATH AND NOT UNDER OATH,
BOTH OF WHICH ARE CRIMES, I
CAN'T --
IT WOULD BE TERRIBLY
DISAPPOINTING TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND --
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT HAS TO BE JUSTICE, EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS OR WE
MIGHT AS WELL JUST TO SHRED THE
CONSTITUTION.
WE CAN'T HAVE A DUAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY AND LOOK
AT ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
PAPADOPOULOS, MANDA FORD, COHEN,
GENERAL FLYNN, WHICH I WANT TO
ASK YOU, WHEN McCABE, WHEN
GENERAL FLYNN SAID WELL, I WILL
NEED A LAWYER McCABE
TOLD HIM NO AND THEN COMEY BRAGS
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING HE
WOULDN'T DO IN THE OBAMA OR
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION
THAT TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE CHAOS
AND SENT HIS GUYS AND WHEN THEY
HAD ALREADY UNMASKED
GENERAL FLYNN, THEY HAD A
CHAPTER AND VERSE ON EVERYTHING
HE SAID.
REMEMBER, THE FBI GUYS DIDN'T
THINK FLYNN WAS LYING.
SO THEN HE ADDRESSED THE
QUESTION, WELL, WHY WOULD HE
ADMIT THAT HE'S LANGUAGE MICHAEL
NUMBER ONE, IS GOING BANKRUPT,
NUMBER TWO, THEY ARE THREATENING
HIS FAMILY.
THEY ARE SAYING WE ARE JUST
GOING TO HAVE TO GO AFTER YOUR
SON, TOO.
I THINK THAT'S WHY HE SAID I
WILL FALL ON THE SWORD FOR MY
FAMILY.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
THAT'S HOW WE TREAT A
33-YEAR-OLD THAT THAT SERVES IN
COMBAT.
>> Sean: McCABE IS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THAT BECAUSE
HE WAS ESSENTIALLY LYING AND
DECEIVING AND TRYING TO ENTRAP
MICHAEL FLYNN TO PURSUE THE
RUSSIA HOAX AGAINST DONALD TRUM
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: DID HE DENIES FLYNN
HIS BASICALLY RECOMMEND A
MIRANDA RIGHTS BY SAYING NO, YOU
DON'T NEED A LAWYER QUESTION MY
>> HE DID AND THEN YOU HEAR ON
TAPE CALLED ME SAYING IT WE
WOULD NEVER TRY THAT WITH ANYONE
ELSE IN ANY OTHER
INITIATION.
THESE TWO GUYS ARE THE SYMBOL OF
MALEVOLENCE AND CORRUPTION AND
IT SHOULD BE FRIGHTENING TO ALL
AMERICANS THAT COMEY AND
McCABE ROSE THROUGH THE RANKS
TO BECOME DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
COME BOTH OF THEM.
>> Sean: SHOULD HE WOULD JUST
WITHDRAW THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY YOU SHOULD ROOT
WITHDRAW THOUGHTFULLY AND I
SUSPECT HE SHOULD.
>> COME THE PRESIDENT CAN CUT
THAT'S ALL SHRED BY PARDONING
THEM.
I WOULD PARDON FLYNN IN A
HEARTBEAT IF I WERE HIM.
STU AND I GREW AT A HUNDRED
PERCENT.
I AGREE WITH BOTH OF YOU BUT WHO
IS GOING TO LISTEN TO LITTLE OLD